in the courtroom greiner listened as the
judge handed down her sentence
nine years imprisonment and a fine of
some sixteen thousand dollars
earlier greiner told the court she had
no intention of breaking any russian law
i made an honest mistake
and i hope
that
in your ruling that it doesn't end my
life here
the biden administration remains adamant
that greiner was wrongfully detained and
the president immediately released a
statement after the judgment saying
it's unacceptable and i call on russia
to release her immediately so she can be
with her wife loved ones friends and
teammates
negotiations are underway to secure
greiner's release and that of another
american citizen who the u.s says is
being wrongfully detained in russia paul
whelan we have permitted a serious
proposal uh to to the russians
to try to get britney and paul whalen
who is also wrongfully detained home
where they belong
and we urge the russians again to
seriously consider that proposal to act
on it
and let's get these two americans home
where they belong
this is a russian being held in the u.s
who could be part of the exchange
victor baut is serving a 25-year
sentence for arms smuggling and
supplying weapons to colombia's farc
movement which is classified by the us
as a terrorist organization
the russian government has been
reluctant to comment
we still think that any information
exchanges on this theme should be
discrete megaphone diplomacy street
exchange views won't lead to the result
we're at a time in a history where the
us and russia have very bad relations
that doesn't help but even in spite of
that in may there was a prisoner swap
between the u.s and russia where trevor
reed who was held in russia was brought
home in exchange for russian prisoners
so there's precedent for it happening
and i think it will happen here too
britney greiner is led away to begin her
sentence
with a message for those waiting at home
i love my family
my hannah al jazeera washington